- Salut ! Aujourd'hui, je suis avec Tao.
Tao il était dans la vidéo je sais pas combien, mais
je vais mettre une petite fiche là-haut pour que vous puissiez revoir la vidéo
c'était aux hallucinations collectives
Je suis CHEZ LUI, à Limoges.
- En mode matinal, toi, ça...
- Ouais (rire)
(Rires) Merci
- Ça se voit aux coupes !
Bah toi aussi
- Et y a mes yeux
- T'as des petits yeux, voilà
Je me suis dit « pour aujourd'hui, on va pas refaire une vidéo où je fais un tour à Tao, où Tao me fait un tour »
Et puis en plus de ça, y avait la vidéo de hier, que j'ai un peu en travers de la gorge
Parce qu'il me manquait des rushs et du coup je suis pas très fier de ce que je vous ai mis dans la vidéo, mais
voilà, pour le défi, fallait quand même que je la sorte malgré le peu de rushs que j'avais.
Aujourd'hui, en temps normal, je devrais faire un tour à quelqu'un, mais on va faire mieux que ça
Puisque Tao s'est proposé pour expliquer... Euh...  Un ou deux tours de magie, c'est ça ?
Oui, oh, même trois, s'ils sont sympas.
Vous savez quoi, pour les tours, je vais vous prendre directement à la main
Comme ça je vais pouvoir bien filmer, de bien près que
vous puissiez bien comprendre !
En 16:9 ?
(Fabien rit)
Première !
Vous reconnaissez tous ce fameux portefeuille, qu'on appelle
un portefeuille avec une sécurité enfant.
Ça je vais... Euh, on va pas trop s'éterniser dessus, mais
juste, un petit tour que je vais vous faire avec un petit billet de 20 €
Qu'on peut emprunter, hein.
Mais bon Fabien, il a pas les moyens, donc, même moi
même quand il vient chez moi, je sors l'argent
Je m'en prends plein la gueule, j'ai rien demandé
Là on a un billet de 20€, donc tout classique, tu peux filmer de près, pour une fois qu'il n'y a pas de truc
Profites-en !
Un véritable billet ?
- Oui !
Y a le filigrane, enfin bon, on voit tout, hein, y a pas de raison.
Regarde bien. Simplement, je le plie en deux, comme ci, on voit bien là
Regarde, j'vais (tu peux me filmer là)... un p'tit crayon
Classique.
Pas en mousse, hein.
Ok.
J'y vais, comme on dirait en Suisse, en slow-motion, regardez-bien
Tu peux le mettre à un endroit et après...
-En Suisse, en slow-motion ?
Comme on dirait en Suisse en slow-motion. Voilà, bon...
(Rires)
Attention, regarde bien, j'y vais tout doucement.
Je pénètre (le billet !). Tout doucement... Blague, ça va, tu suis ?
- Ouais, c'est bon.
Et attention, regardez bien... Je fais ça...
Tac.
Je sais pas si t'arrives à voir ici, Fabien ?
- Tout à fait, monsieur.
- Gros plan, donc bien à l'intérieur ici
C'est ce qu'on appelle, dans le monde financier, avoir un trou dans son budget.
D'accord ?
Il suffit juste de traverser complètement le crayon à travers.
Et là, le seul moyen de pouvoir réparer ce trou que vous avez dans le budget, c'est soit
d'attendre la fin du mois, ou le début du mois, ou alors
prendre le crayon comme une baguette magique, dire la formule
non pas « abracadabra », mais pour les tours avec des billets, faut dire juste Cahuzac
*rires de Fabien*
Et au bout d'un moment, si on déplie le billet, t'as vraiment l'impression d'avoir loupé un truc
- AMAZING !
Mais j'ai envie de vous dire « mais comment ça fonctionne monsieur Tao ? »
- Je sais pas du tout !
En fait, il faut une toute petite préparation. Si tu filmes là
Juste une toute petite fente, que tu fais ça au cutter
de un, ou deux, ouais de un centimètre
- Ah oui, d'accord ! Je l'avais pas vu
- Je croyais vraiment que tu te moquais de moi
- Ouais, beh non
Regarde, je sais pas, si on se met sur le...
Je vais passer le crayon là, qu'on le voit bien
Ok ?
- Ouais
- Voilà, donc à peu près juste après le filigrane.
Ce qui me permet, en fait, quand je plie le billet, de montrer
qu'il y a une bonne marge là, et de montrer que vraiment le crayon ne passe pas derrière
Parce que si on fait ça, on a vraiment l'impression que ça passe derrière alors que
si y a un décalage, tu prends le crayon, tu fais sa life derrière, et je vous montre
qu'est-ce qui se passe du côté magicien ?
Tac, ici, ça passe ici, dans le trou, de face. Ça fait ça, on a vraiment l'illusion que c'est à l'intérieur.
L'avantage, c'est qu'on peut tenir le crayon comme ça
Pour vraiment montrer l'illusion que ça traverse
Là, tu vois, ça traverse complètement.
- Oui, parce que la partie qu'on a envie d'examiner
C'est là, là
- Exactement ! C'est vraiment au milieu du billet
Alors que la fente est en décalage.
Quand vous dépliez le billet, les deux mains, les deux doigts
sont sur la fente, là, que vous avez fait (qui est juste là)
Ce qui fait que ça cache, vous pouvez vraiment tirer le billet pour montrer que c'est reconstitué
- Donc quand tu dis « billet emprunté » tu te foutais de nous.
- On peut l'emprunter, mais faut préparer la fente. Vous allez aux toilettes
vite fait avec votre cutter... (Rires) Mais sinon, voilà.
- Cool !
- C'est vraiment un véritable billet.
Je vais prendre juste un petit sachet de sucre, ici
Je me rapproche, que tu les entendes bien
(les sachets font le bruit de sachets pleins)
T'es super loin... On pourrait le faire à une personne, vois si tu peux tendre ta main
- Oui, regarde.
-Tu préfères quel sachet ?
- Euh... Celui-ci !
- Celui-ci alors ?
- Oui !
- Alors on va l'utiliser vraiment pour la caméra
- D'accord
Je vais te filer celui-là, tu peux vérifier que t'as vraiment du sucre aussi.
(Fabien secoue : le sachet fait un bruit de sucre)
Ok ?
J'enlève mon sachet, ok ? Je vais le mettre... de côté...
Regarde bien. Je vous montre ici, là, ma main, pour les magiciens pas d'EFP, super !
(Rires)
Voilà. Vous pouvez mettre un pouce bleu.
Je vais vous montrer, regardez. Tout doucement... tu verses...
Regarde, y en a un petit peu qui dépasse là, je sais pas si...
- Ouais ouais, y en a bien, ouais.
Ok, on va laisser un petit peu. Regarde.
Ok ? Juste dans ma poche, là.
Et si vous croyez fortement à la magie, au bout d'un moment, si on chauffe
un peu la matière
Tout doucement avec les mains, rien qu'avec la chaleur humaine
Tu vas vraiment avoir l'impression que tout doucement, tous les grains de sucre
Disparaîssent ici totalement.
Quand vous avez le cutter, là, vous allez toujours dans les toilettes
Et vous faites une petite fente sur un sachet de sucre que vous avez pris
au comptoir du bar
Ce sucre-là, vous allez vous en débarrasser euh...
- Dans les toilettes, du coup.
- Dans les toilettes, voilà, directement.
(On va le prendre un petit peu plus grand, c'est histoire de vous montrer que...)
Pourquoi on en avait deux ? Parce que celui qui est plein
et donc celui que vous avez vidé, vous en gardez un tout petit peu quand même
Pour montrer qu'à la fin, il y a du sucre là.
Et quand vous avez le deuxième, vous secouez
Vous avez vraiment l'impression que les deux sachets...
- Oui parce qu'on entend le bruit de l'autre sachet en fait
si vous regardez dans la vidéo, on le voit
- Voilà ! Et après vous en choisissez un
celui qui est vide, de préférence. Et là, comme ça se voit pas, vous déchirez, ce qui fait que ça élimine
la préparation, la fente que vous avez fait. Comme ça, au moins, c'est examinable.
Vous posez ça, vous faites semblant d'ouvrir ceci, vous montrez bien que la main est vide
Vous versez tout ça, et comme il reste quelques grains de sucre
ça vous permet de vraiment vider là. Et au bout d'un moment, tac, on a
vraiment l'impression que tout le sachet de sucre disparaît.
- Alors moi je connaissais la version que tu fais avec le spectateur
- Ouais
- Avec la personne et les 2 déchires en même temps
- Exactement
- Les 2 mettent dans leur main en même temps
sauf que... à la fin le magicien n'a plus rien et le spectateur a plein de sucre dans les mains
C'est un petit truc marrant à faire à la fin d'un repas.
- mais pour une raison de budget on avait pas de partenaire
*rires*
- mais ça tombe bien que tu me dises ça parce qu'on va enchaîner sur autre chose. Tu tiens bien la caméra?
- Et bien je tiens.
- Tiens la caméra parce que
- *rire* vous savez que ce mec n'arrête jamais, mais jamais
jamais
-  Comme on est pas à la télé, on a le temps
donc comme Fabien disait le spectateur, fait la chose, donc imagines c'est moi qui joue le rôle du spectateur
-Ouais
- Je fais ça là. Il verse dans sa main
- Exactement
- Donc là tu vois on voit vraiment vraiment le sucre ici
y'en a plein plein
Bon ben madame fera le ménage *rires* donc là on voit le sucre
donc c'est que le spectateur il reste comme un...
comment on pourrait dire comme un...?
- un gentleman
- Voilà exactement
*rires*
- avec plein plein de sucre, il ouvre et le problème c'est qu'il y a pleins de sucre
alors qu'est ce qu'on pourrait faire? Et bien on pourrait enchaîner avec ça
au lieu de faire du gâchis
- ouais
- Donc en fait, on... on dit à la personne de mettre le sucre dans une tasse
je vais vraiment tout tout doucement
- Je peux leur faire voir l'intérieur?
- Oui oui bien sûr excuses moi
- tac
- C'est bon?
Voilà ok
tu peux bien filmer bon j'ai un peu de sucre ici, attends on va le mettre sur la table excuse moi
*se frotte les mains* voilà verser le sucre ok
et... ce qu'on appelle une routine en magie. En fait, c'est une combinaison de plusieurs numéros
On a fait disparaître le sucre, le spectateur tient toujours le sucre et au lieu de ne rien faire avec
il le met dans cette tasse
vous montrez maintenant, qu'on peut faire de la magie avec ça
il suffit juste de montrer les 2 mains vides. Tu es prêt Fabien?
- Oui
- Je met juste ma main en dessous, pareil toujours avec la chaleur humaine, on fait ça
Et si on fait ça, si on secoue un petit peu. Vous allez voir qu'au bout d'un moment
si vous croyez à la magie on peut transformer, ici, le sucre en café
regardez bien tout doucement, je vais, sans coupure de caméra,
et là tu as vraiment l'impression que
- Oooooh
- Du café soluble à la place du sucre
- Il est bon ton café El Gringo
- Merci beaucoup
L'explication est automatique
Vous prenez du café soluble en grain. Tu peux filmer maintenant qu'on a compris
c'est du gros grain qu'il faut prendre il faut pas prendre celui qui est en poudre
étant donné que le grain est légèrement plus gros que le sucre
vous voyez le sucre est en dessous
ok donc là ça se voit pas. Donc là, la tasse est préparée à l'avance avec le
- avec le café au fond.
toi tu mets le sucre par au dessus
- Exactement donc à la hauteur des yeux des gens
pour montrer au spectateur qui est là. Vous lui dites tu mets le sucre à l'intérieur
comme ça les gens ne voient pas ce qu'il y a au fond
Une fois que tu as mis le sucre ça va recouvrir
- Ouais
-Tous les grains
- Oui on a vu sur la vidéo
- Exact
et après vous avez plus qu'à mettre votre main comme si vous étiez un vrai magicien
Et en secouant légèrement
- avec un peu de force centrifuge
-Exactement
et vous ouvrez la main, le sucre a disparu ça devient vraiment du café
- On a 38min de vidéos, on va s'arrêter là
Merci d'avoir regarder cette vidéo. J'espère que ça vous aura plu que c'était clair
N'hésitez pas à le refaire pour bluffer des gens, répétez le un petit peu.
si ces tour là vous ont plu n'hésitez pas à nous le laissait savoir en laissant un petit
Pouce en l'air
vous pouvez également vous abonner à la chaine
N'oubliez pas le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an donc rendez vous demain à 17h pour le prochain Mental Vlog
Ciao!